These were the main proposals of the
presidential candidates during yesterday's debate.
Claudia Sheinbaum,
candidate of Morena PT and the green party,
proposes to continue investing in the IMSS welfare program,
to continue with the ideology of austerity and to strengthen the
educational system under the concept of the new inclusive school.
Xochitl Gálvez,
PRI candidate,
pan and p.
RD,
distributes smart cards to guarantee health services in
public or private instances that will be paid with the heir.
He said that he developed the necessary locks to prevent the
illicit movements of public officials and also proposes
robotic technology classes and tablets for basic education students.
Jorge Álvarez Maines,
the candidate in the citizens' movement,
mentions that he intends to put an end to the Partidocracy,
a system of transparency for companies and a single window of
procedures to stop acts of corruption in the management processes.
Tell us what you thought of the proposals.